people tend to think that money and
finance is this unemotional thing that's
actually not the case
it's deeply rooted in the traumas that
have created the society
that we continue to see inequalities
prosper
when we're trying to dismantle those
systems
i'm chloe mckenzie i'm the founder and
ceo of black
femme black femme is making communities
better
because we are implementing financial
education
five days a week as a core subject
starting in elementary school
so that black girls and girls of color
have
the skills habits and resources to build
and sustain wealth
we've seen students perform better
a standard deviation in their math and
english language arts test scores
because
they are receiving our curriculum five
days a week
even though we care most about closing
the wealth gap for black women and girls
black feminist teaching tells us that if
you liberate those who are at the bottom
you're actually liberating everybody
so we could do so in a way that takes
this radical idea of closing wealth gap
for black girls
and ensuring that all students who work
with our curriculum
are receiving financial literacy five
days a week
as a core subject during the school day
we typically see financial literacy
happening after school so you're only
going to reach a certain population
i wanted every single kid to get it
every single day
for at least 45 minutes and that's what
we're doing in
school districts across the country a
lot of people heard it it was like
like what are we going to teach kids
that's in the second grade like that's
too much for them like some
teachers had that mindset and some was
willing to embrace it i just felt like i
was willing to embrace it
even if i got you know one or two kids
to understand or
just strike their interests it was a
success to me
[Music]
school was everything to me i'm not
really sure why but i've always just
loved learning i actually skipped two
grades so
you know the kind of idea of being a
nerd was something that i
really took to heart and really embraced
and enjoyed for me
what i found to be so important to my
trajectory and the work that i do in the
world
was the fact that i had an enabling
environment
i had teachers who understood my passion
for history
and my passion for understanding and
studying injustices
today we're here to talk about one of my
former students chloe mckenzie
chloe and i came to know each other when
she first
entered in my previous high school and
she commanded my attention the moment
i'd say i met her she has always been
passionate about what she believes in
i think i've always had this motto of
service
is how you heal mr mccluskey is actually
one of the
people who helped me understand that
black femme will be coming to this
school
and of course because mr mccluskey was
the reason why i got into social justice
it's a big theme here in the school
community we are in bethesda maryland
right outside washington dc we're here
now because
in my new role as a principal i want to
do some partnership with chloe
in her new role with black femme the way
that wealth was created in america
was through stolen indigenous land and
through black bodies
and so the fact that my body was a
source of wealth
but that i didn't have any value
inherently as a person
is something that lives within us our
education system
is inadequately supporting certain
groups of students as it is
black girls being one of them and our
schools also don't have
this intention to set our students up
for financial success i see the work
that chloe is doing
she knows that this work and black femme
is going to make a difference
in the lives of young people i think
what's so great about the generation
that's in high school right now
is there's this very strong intention
and rigor to be able to create a better
world for themselves
and so we're really going to be
identifying how financial activism
can be something that these students
here engage in
and prepare to not only build wealth but
then use their financial activism at the
same time to change our communities
the narratives that we're providing to
students get them to think that they
need to be on this journey or this
pursuit for more above
all else rather than thinking about what
is it that i really want and how do i
fund that vision
and that's really what wealth is